iPhone 14 pro Max versus 15 Pro Max are
they really that different well we are
going to compare everything from the
design the displays the speakers the
performance and even the 5G speed plus
much more that other reviewers did not
test or talk about as you guys could see
we have a bunch of new iPhones and we're
gonna do a bunch of real world videos
that are very interesting so make sure
you guys hit that subscribe button down
below now I on purpose did not look at
the new iPhones when I went to the Apple
store this morning to pick these up
because I wanted to give an honest First
Impressions so let's take a look at that
and video that looks a lot different
than the pictures it looked a lot warmer
for the natural color which this one is
okay let's pick it up guys this feels so
much lighter in the hand this is just
the front of it uh still heavy it's not
like it's an iPhone 15 small size but
that is nice let's flip this around
I like that the stickers are messed up
here but we have a matte finish on the
side that curve on the back isn't as
noticeable as I thought it would be but
you know what holding these side by side
okay now it's a big difference you don't
have those sharp edges that are poking
into your hands
um but you still have that nice grip
from the sides that are flat to help you
hold your phone so this is really the
best of both worlds now I also feel that
the matte is actually a little bit more
matte or a little more Satin as far as
the feeling and I really like that the
sides aren't very sticky uh with this
kind of shiny side it just feels nicer
in the hand and with this natural color
if you get a scratch on it you're not
going to really notice it as much unlike
the blue ones which are already showing
scratches so this is very similar to the
Apple watch where I've had this Ultra
for a year here and I have no scratches
on it now the 15 Pros glass back can
actually shatter easier than the 14 Pros
because of that curved Edge but as a
bonus it is much much cheaper to replace
that back glass because of the redesign
okay this is interesting the power
button is actually quieter than on the
old one but it feels nicer almost like
it's more clicky but not as loud and
then let's go to the other side here and
compare these buttons size wise the
buttons are similar but the new ones are
a lot more clicky they feel really good
and then of course we do not have that
mute switch anymore but we have this
action button which also feels really
nice to press it actually requires more
pressure to press it down which is nice
and we'll test how that new action
button works of course we have the new
USB type-c port which is larger than
lightning and we have a lot of camera
upgrades in these cameras look
surprisingly different we're going to
cover those in detail in just a bit but
now let me set up the phone but before I
move on I want to show you guys this the
new snap invisible tripod stand from our
partner moft which is a super slim Max
safe accessory which instantly unfolds
into a floating tripod making it the
smallest quickest and most versatile
tripod stand in the world with angle
adjustability perfect for Content
creators who are always on the go since
no other traditional tripod can be put
away and carried so quickly like this it
features moth's new soft and durable
movas vegan leather finish in four
colors and it offers a bunch of modes
like browsing macro photography video
call theater mode and more but my
favorite one that I'm going to be using
a lot is this finally fixing the issue
of needing a good stand for taking group
photos with friends or even selfie mode
for when I record tick tocks or shorts
and it is perfect for iOS 17's new
standby mode and the best part is when
you are done you simply fold it up into
a super slim portable design so you can
go and create anywhere so check out the
link in the description below to order
mop's invisible phone stand today and
now looking at the displays we could see
how much thinner the bezels are on the
new 15 Pro Max it is dramatic side by
side and these are the thinnest bezels
that are all even all around the display
so it looks really nice it makes it look
smaller and in fact if we go ahead and
set them side by side the new 15 Pro Max
is actually slightly shorter and
slightly narrower than the 14 pro Max
which also adds to comfort in the hand
now as far as the display brightness
they are identical the same thing with
the quality HDR video Peak brightness
everything is the same the actual
technology for the panels have not
changed but they are still excellent and
now on to the action button I have loved
the Hardware switch on the iPhones
because even in my pocket I just go
ahead and flick it make sure it's on
silent mode but I usually kept it in
silent mode now we have this action
button let's try it out
okay guys
but you have you felt this yet no yeah
yeah the haptics are incredibly strong
it literally just pulls us multiple
times super strong so you know that it's
in silent mode when you switch back to
regular it's just one little haptic
feedback so even in your pocket let me
go ahead and try this out it is very
easy to know which mode you put it in
now of course the coolest thing is that
you can customize it so here I'm in the
action mode settings we have this really
cool graphic so you can change to focus
modes camera flashlight voice memos
magnifier shortcuts and we have some
other stuff now I'm personally excited
about the camera so let's go ahead and
switch it to that and we'll test it out
I'm gonna go ahead and hold down the
button here bam the camera app opened up
really quickly so screen is off press
and hold and look at this you can use
the same action button when you're in
the app to take a photo right away let
me see how quick I could do this okay
hold down press
how long would that take video dude that
was like a split second okay let's try
that again
hold down
press that was probably less than a
second and I think it's faster than
having to turn your screen on press and
hold here and then take the picture and
you can also customize what the camera
app does so we have selfie video
portrait portrait selfie to go into
those modes automatically so that is
sweet now another thing you could do is
the shortcuts this is super cool apple
is not limiting us so I'm going to
select open app I'm going to go through
here and let's select the Tesla app that
way right away you could just press the
button down and then you can go straight
into your Tesla app to be able to unlock
your car uh maybe open up the trunk or
the front really quickly and easily so
that is a really nice upgrade from the
14 pro Max and to be honest so far I am
really impressed with the changes and
the things that they have added but the
next thing is going to be the speaker
comparison Apple rarely talks about
speaker improvements but most years we
noticed differences sometimes huge ones
so let's go ahead and take a listen
[Music]
foreign
wow that is a noticeable difference even
though the 15 Pro Max is smaller the
sound is quite a bit louder and they
actually tune the higher frequencies to
stand out more in the past they actually
detune that not sure why but this is a
nice Improvement in terms of sound
quality you guys let me know what you
think down below and now we need to talk
about that USB type-c port it's not only
a change for charging of course you can
now use the same cable for your iPad for
your MacBook and your iPhone but Apple
gave us a lot more capabilities for
example the first thing is you can
actually plug a lightning cable in or a
USBC cable and you could charge another
phone with it which is really nice and
helpful you can charge an Android phone
with that you can actually take airpods
and you can connect them and you can
charge those as well you can also charge
your Apple watch if you have your
charger with you so that is really nice
to have now of course we also have 20
times faster transfers but the original
cable the one that comes in the Box this
nice braided cable it does not have
those speeds it's just as slow as the
old lighting one so you do have to get a
different cable even though this one is
high quality now this also gives you
more abilities you can take one of these
razor coolers which has a USB type-c
connection and this one is magsafe we
did a full video on it and as you guys
could see it is on it is running and it
is cooling the phone which is going to
be great for gaming if you guys want us
to make a video testing out the gaming
performance on the 15 Pros let us know
down in the comments section below now
with that you can actually connect the
iPhone to an external display and it
will mirror everything without ugly bars
on the sides you can even a game and
have that on display as well which is
cool and you can get a cheap external
SSD with us be type c plug it right into
your phone and right away you guys could
see right there two terabyte sabrant SSD
I can transfer files really quickly and
with that you can also use it to record
prores onto the SSD directly to save
space and save time so I would say the
change to USB type-c is a much bigger
deal than we first thought and now let's
go ahead and get into performance the
first thing I want to start out with is
the memory disk Speed most people don't
test that both of these are 256 gig
models so let's see if we have any
improvements and looking at the results
the read speeds are very similar in fact
the 14 per Max is slightly faster now in
terms of write speeds well the 14 per
Max is going crazy slow now that might
just be because my phone is practically
full and I look back at last year's test
and the write speeds pretty much match
up and it looks like if your phone is
full it is going to be slowing down so
not much of a difference there I have
geekbench 6 opened up right here and as
you guys could see we have the a16
bionic this one is not listed yet but
the a17 pro and for Ram we have six gigs
compared to eight that is a nice boost
it'll allow apps to stay open longer in
the background without Auto closing now
the clock speeds are also higher we have
3.78 compared to 3.46 but that is if
thermals don't get in the way so let's
go ahead and run this alright guys here
we go we have a score of 29.25 compared
to 2600 that is a 10.7 difference in
terms of single core and as far as
multi-core we are in the seven thousands
but that is only a nine percent
difference and if you compare the
previous Apple iPhone launches and with
new Chips well this is not that big of a
difference and now let's compare the
graphics the new a17 pro has an extra
GPU core we have six cores compared to
five so let's see how big of a
difference that makes and look at that
we have exactly 20 difference between
them 27 000 compared to twenty two
thousand so Apple was spot on in terms
of
um what they said at their event now
this is for metal there's a lot of
compute tasks let's go ahead and open up
3dmark I'm gonna run Wildlife extreme
unlimited which is gonna push these to
the Max and this is very interesting if
we look at the raw numbers here we have
19.7 FPS compared to 17.2 very little
difference for average that's about 15
but if we look at the chart at the start
the 15 Pro Max was hitting slightly
above 30 FPS at Peak compared to 24 and
that's a 25 difference but then as we
went on the 15 Pro Max lost more of his
performance giving us us a much closer
score overall so that could just be
throttling where it gets great
performance but not for that long and of
course this is a tough test and this is
something that could be helped with a
cooler which we'll check out in the
future yeah the next test is a brand new
one this is solar Bay and it is designed
to test out Ray tracing because the new
a17 pro has hardware for that built in
I'm going to go ahead and start this
test now this is going to be great for
gaming Apple showed it off having really
good Reflections making it more
realistic but with that certain programs
for example 3D rendering can also make
use of Ray tracing to speed things up
dramatically and we got the scores looks
like we have 23.3 FPS on average
compared to 14.8 that's a 57 difference
between them now that is a really good
Improvement but on stage Apple said four
times faster using Hardware than
software now I'm not 100 sure if this is
using that Hardware range tracing or
it's fully optimized or maybe it's just
the faster processor and we'll have to
dig into that in the future but we do
see a difference now one Trend that we
are seeing is that this a17 gets quite
hot in the performance drops so the next
thing I'm going to do is open up antutu
Benchmark right here this thing pushes
the graphics to the limits let's go
ahead and start that test and this is
where we see screen dimming just like if
you are playing games for a long time so
let's see if the iPhone 15 Pro Max is
better at that now it does seem that the
15 Pro Max is a little bit smoother it's
not as choppy so that's a nice
Improvement I did make the screens
pretty bright when I'm playing in
brighter rooms or Outdoors i max out the
brightness and of course that with
gaming really heats up your phone oh I
just saw the 14 pro Max did its first
dimming step not a huge one but it was
noticeable people and just then the 15
Pro Max dimmed but now it's weird the 14
pro Max looks brighter almost like the
15 for Max Wait Another Minute minute
and a half before dimming but it dimmed
more so so not great news oh just then
the 14 pro Max dimmed in multiple steps
so both of them are struggling so I
pulled out my thermal camera here and
what you guys could see is on the right
hand side the 14 pro Max the heat is
more spread out where the 15 Pro Max it
is more kind of confined to that chip
area which doesn't help that performance
and looking at the maximum temperatures
I'm seeing 39 on the 14 pro Max
and 40 on the 15 Pro Max so we could
tell that overheating has not been
improved in fact it might actually be
worse and the new titanium design it
could hinder the performance of cooling
and the way the heat spreads so we did
not get an improvement and now I want to
test out cellular connection speeds now
the 15 Pro Max also supports Wi-Fi 6E
that is new but we don't have a router
here or fast enough internet but I can
test out 5G both these are on T-Mobile
and I'm going to run one at a time here
we got 247 download and 15 upload here
inside of our office I'm going to start
the next one here and we're connected to
the same server as far as our reception
we have the same exact and it looks like
look at that right away we are getting
faster speeds and that is because the 15
Max has the new Snapdragon x 70 modem it
has been updated oh is it gonna hit 400
no that was close though very close
maybe if the test was a little bit
longer now upload sitting about 13
slightly worse uh but after this I'm
gonna go outside and test that out as
well that is 60 faster in terms of
download speed on the same network same
server and even having the same
reception that is a big deal that also
could mean that in some places where you
have almost no signal or none you might
get it better now let's head outside
testing the 14 pro Max first the speeds
definitely got noticeably faster we had
four bars of signal now and then the
upload it also shot way up to
66.1 with the 15 Pro Max our speeds also
got faster but not by that much and the
upload once again is slightly slower so
here looking at the results here still
faster on the download load but we are
using mid band 5G which means that's not
the ultra high speed so we could be
maxing out the network here but one
thing for sure the speeds are faster
especially indoors where you have a nice
Improvement even in a building with
concrete walls here so that is a nice
upgrade in this 5G chip and the new
phone it actually uses less power as
well and now let's talk about the
cameras the biggest difference is the
fact that we now have a 5x lens on the
15 Pro Max now the rest of the cameras
are identical but we have some software
updates Apple added a new 24 megapixel
mode to the new 15 lineup but the size
difference only three megabytes compared
to two now with the 14 pro Max they did
allow us to shoot hiff files up to 48
megapixel but not everybody's going to
do that especially if you're gonna take
portraits and live photos so let's take
a look at the Quality difference zooming
into these two images you can see that
the 24 megapixel file has way more
detail I can actually read out some of
the letters but they are all blurred out
on the 12 megapixel file and that
applies to portraits and live photos as
well so here I have a portrait shot of
Vadim let's go ahead and zoom in here a
little bit you guys could see that he is
definitely more crisp now we do have
overcast lighting but you can clearly
see the extra detail and I love that for
portraits now what about the difference
with the 5x lens here's a shot it's very
very similar we can zoom in right here
and if we take a look once again the 5x
lens just looks so much more detailed
than the 3x and both of these are
actually 12 megapixel looks a lot
sharper there's actually some mistakes
here from the sharpening algorithm so
that is nice if you like to zoom in and
I do but what about if you don't need 5x
does the quality get a lot worse because
you're cropping from that main sensor I
took this shot at 4.9 x so the 14 is
actually able to use a 3X lens and then
zoom in where here we are cropping from
the main sensor look at that oh my
goodness
um we can't even read any of that text
that's actually a lot worse than I
expected so if you're going to be
zooming in much much past three well you
want to be switching to the five meaning
sometimes you're gonna have to walk
backwards now this next shot both these
are at 3x indoors so lower lighting and
I have to say that I was actually
impressed by the crop from the 48
megapixel I thought it would actually
look worse but it doesn't it does look
better so 3x is not a big deal with the
15 Pro Max now one worry that I had is
that the new 5x is going to be bad in
low light but both of these here at 5 5x
in low light you could see that the 15
Pro Max definitely looks better than the
14 pro Max I mean that's a nice detail
contrast and color difference so that is
great and then with that 5x lens you can
still take portrait shots at 120
millimeter equivalent so you guys can
see here we have more compression you
see less of the background that's great
for distracting areas you can really
blur stuff out now with this 3x portrait
actually walked closer which you can do
the shot still looks great but you have
some differences now I also zoomed into
vadim's face and the 5x is a lot more
detailed than that 3x lens Apple's been
using this lens for a very long time and
it's actually the same one that is
included in the 15 Pro it doesn't get
that 5x lens so that is surprising to me
I was not expecting it now of course the
15 Pro lineup they have smart hdr5 some
better processing now another thing
that's limited to the new 15 series is
being able to get a portrait shot even
when you didn't take a portrait so at
the bottom left hand side you get that
little portion button that will show up
and it saves the data and then I can go
and hit edit and hit portrait and I will
be able to make a non-portrait phone
Moto into portrait you can adjust the
depth just like you could you can even
change focus and this is the result
which is super cool to be able to do
this so we're gonna do more camera
comparisons we love doing the blind
style where you guys can follow along
with us and participate so make sure you
guys hit that subscribe button if you
guys want to see a lot more about the
cameras so with all those tests
completed is the iPhone 15 Pro Max a
good update from the 14 pro Max at
Apple's event a lot of people said that
this is one of the worst updates
actually I kind of said that as well but
I have to be honest using them right now
so seeing all of the differences I am
more impressed than I thought I would
now of course I'm going to be doing a
one week later real world comparison
between these two all the differences I
notice and those always bring a lot of
very interesting things so make sure you
guys click that Circle up button above
to subscribe so you don't miss out check
out one of those great videos right up
there this has been Max and I will see
you in the next one
[Music]
foreign